bonjour à tous permettez moi d'abord
avoir une pensée
ambre toutes les victimes du bataclan et
tous nos pays toutes nos pensées vont
vers eux aujourd'hui je voulais d'abord
vous remercier de me recevoir
moi qui suis le champion du monde en
france du redoublement
je considère être le plus mauvais élève
de l'éducation nationale ce qui donne
beaucoup d'espoir beaucoup de monde et
pour une raison très simple j'ai
redoublé ma 5e j'ai raté mon brevet des
collèges
j'ai retapé mon bac je retape et trois
fois mon deuil deux fois ma licence deux
fois le concours d'avocat donc ça fait
bien neuf en réalité on 19 mai c'est
sans la tva parce que là trois fois
trois années où j'ai signé à la place de
mes parents ils l'ont su quand j'ai
publié ce livre et j'ai signé à blast de
mes parents 6e en 4e bon 4e j'avais un
plâtre donc c'est un ami qui a signé
pour moi et en première même si j'ai eu
15 15 au bac français est en réalité
j'étais pas aussi nul que ça parce que
certains me l'ont dit mais lorsque vous
êtes dans une situation difficile et
compliqué c'est que d'abord au considère
pour certains que vous êtes mauvais et
lorsque dans le regard des autres vous
êtes mauvais vous pensez l'être et ce
n'était pas le cas en réalité personne
n'est mauvais personne n'est mauvais mes
parents ont quitté l'iran en 1979
nous sommes nés ici avec mon frère
jumeau à paris on a mené notre petit
bonhomme de chemin et j'ai pris mon
indépendance
à 19 ans un petit studio de 20 m² mon
loyer était de 800 euros de 400 euros et
mon loyer et mon ma rémunération
mon salaire était de 800 euros donc je
vive avec 400 euros par mois je
bricolais j'étais frustré j'étais amer
je me disais pourquoi moi je suis dans
une telle difficulté et donc je suis
rentré dans une spirale catastrophique
l'échec l'échec appelle les chèques
j'étais mauvais en cours je me bagarrais
mon frère jumeau réussissait mais moi
j'étais pas bon et j'avais honte
j'avais honte de moi et j'avais honte
également parce que j'avais pas de fric
j'allais au mcdo ma carte bleue été
refusé et je peux vous garantir que
c'est vraiment une humiliation parce que
vous avez une file d'attenté derrière
des gens qui vous disent mais on est
pressé monsieur dépêchez-vous et que le
caissier vous dis mais n'y a pas
d'argent sur votre compte en banque
monsieur mettez vous sur le côté où
aller chercher de l'argent ils
revenaient et donc vous avez dans cette
spirale
l'idée de réussir dans vos études parce
que mon rêve à moi était devenir avocat
c'était mon rêve
j'avais envie d'aider les gens j'avais
envie d'aider les pauvres
j'avais envie d'aider les démunis mais
j'ai échoué
alors comment j'ai fait je me suis
accroché aux branches
j'ai utilisé la technique du nénuphar
les petites victoires appelé les petites
victoires
j'ai réussi à voir mon baccalauréat en
1999 et la même année au bout de la
troisième fois j'ai réussi à avoir mon
permis de conduire
je me suis raccroché à ces petites
bronches à ces petites victoires et
chose extraordinaire c'est que chaque
année lorsque je montais je me disais
plus que quatre en tout que trois ans
avant de devenir avocat ou alors je me
disais une autre version encore trois
quatre ans et je ne pourrai plus me
faire refuser de faire ramper empêché de
devenir avocat parce qu'évidemment
chaque année on vous dit voilà il ya
encore cette porte de sortie bep c'est à
payer tout alors que je ne voulais pas y
aller je voulais aller en général sauf
qu'à l'époque quand il n'y avait pas
internet
on pouvait pas aller chercher sur google
aussi facilement donc du coup je me
renseigne et je m'informais et on me
disait voilà pour faire avocat il faut
aller faire tel chemin alors je me suis
battu j'ai utilisé ce qu'on appelle les
cheminées les portes de sortie
on me refusait la porte de sortie
je rentrais par la cheminée la fenêtre
et comment ça s'est passé concrètement
après ma licence que j'ai eu avec
acharnement
je suis allé à la licence je suis
ensuite fait une ensuite fait une master
2 et j'ai eu ensuite passé soutenu une
thèse de droit
je vais utiliser la passerelle et c'est
une chose que chacun de nous doit
utiliser les passerelles vous devez
garder votre rêve systématiquement
toujours gardé son rêve mais gardé son
rêve en étant dans une réalité signifie
qu'il ya plusieurs chemins pour vous
permettre d'y accéder souvent moi je
vois des gens qui au bout d'un ou deux
et chaque échelon il échoue peut-être
parfois pour un rien un tout petit peu
abandonné partent vers d'autres chemins
mais non vous devez jamais abandonné
vous avez un rêve
vous ne devez pas lâcher ça peut prendre
un an deux ans trois ans dix ans vingt
ans c'est pas grave moi j'ai commencé en
1999 ma première année droit
j'ai prêté serment tenez vous bien en
février 2018 j'ai mis dix neuf ans 19
ans et en parallèle de ça j'ai voulu
renvoyer l'ascenseur à mon pays je
considère qu'une année scolaire ces cent
mille euros que le pays investit sur moi
et sur chacun nous tous donc j'ai décidé
de me faire élire en parallèle j'ai
décidé de renvoyer l'ascenseur mon pays
qui nous a accueilli chacune mes parents
qui nous a fait grandir qui investit sur
nous qui nous a transmis les valeurs de
la république liberté égalité fraternité
donc j'ai décidé de me faire élire comme
conseiller municipal dans ma ville à
courbevoie et je me suis dit il ya un
scandale
moi je les subis puisque je voyais de la
nourriture jetée dans les poubelles
chaque soir je n'ai pas beaucoup
d'argent
je regardais de la nourriture
consommables jeter dans les poubelles je
me suis dit je vais me faire élire je
vais faire interdire ça je me suis battu
avec des amis on a commencé une pétition
en janvier 2015 février 2016 en un an
une loi a été votée à l'unanimité notre
parlement français une première dans le
monde qui oblige les supermarchés a
redonné les invendus alimentaire
consommables à l'association de son
choix si un citoyen peu importe lequel
créé sa propre association va demander
les invendus alimentaire au supermarché
ton choix avec le supermarché refuse
c'est une amende de 10000 euros
nous avons porté plainte contre leclerc
franprix carrefour grâce à cette loi
plus de 10 millions de repas sont
distribués chaque année en france
c'est une hausse de plus de 22 % du don
alimentaire j'ai considéré voilà que
c'était une petite goutte d'eau pour
notre pays une petite goutte d'eau que
chacun de nous ici peuvent faire et peut
intégrer essayez c'est comme ça que j'ai
voulu voir les choses positives et mon
énergie systématiquement c'est à dire
que dans 1 20 mètre carré y avoir
derrière ya encore dix jours
le prix nobel et la première
déclarations que j'ai faites
quand j'ai reçu ce prix nobel du
développement durable à göteborg j'ai
dit voilà ce prix c'est pas moi parce
que moi je suis que de passage
ce prix c'est pour la france et pour
notre pays parce que le rêve français
existent encore lorsque vous avez des
rêves vous devez pas le lâcher
je vous remercie beaucoup
[Applaudissements]